c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir le mali qui accuse une
puissance extrarégionale d'être à
l'origine d'une tentative de coup d'état
bamako affirme l'avoir déjoué la semaine
dernière est arrêté à des officiers
maliens à la solde de cette puissance
décryptage dans un instant avec notre
invité jérôme qui n'y est président et
cofondateur du réseau de réflexion
stratégique sur la sécurité au sahel
le désespoir au burkina faso pour les
familles des huit mineurs portés
disparus depuis l'inondation du 14 avril
les mineurs n'ont pas été retrouvés par
les secouristes dans la deuxième chambre
de refuge qui pouvait les recueillir les
réactions dans ce journal et à la fin de
cette édition vous proposera le portrait
d'un jeune immigré sénégalais le jeune
homme qui a grandi en italie s'est rendu
célèbre dans le monde entier grâce au
réseau social clic toc reportage à
suivre
une tentative de coup d'état at elle été
déjoué au mali c'est en tout cas ce
qu'affirment les militaires au pouvoir
il pointe du doigt des officiers maliens
aux ordres d'un état occidental sans le
nommer les faits seraient survenus la
semaine dernière analyse fort tad
bulletin spécial à la télévision d'état
malienne un groupuscule d'officiers et
de sous-officiers
anti progressiste malien a tenté un coup
d'état
dans la nuit du 11 au 12 mai 2022 ces
militaires étaient soutenus pour l'année
terres occidentales
que s'est il passé quel est l'état
occidental incriminés pour l'heure
aucune précision n'est apportée par la
junte qui fait état de plusieurs
arrestations et du renforcement des
contrôles aux frontières
cette annonce fait suite au retrait
retentissant dimanche soir du pays de la
force conjointe du g5 sahel créée en
2014 avec la mauritanie le burkina faso
le niger et le tchad bamako devait en
prendre la présidence en février dernier
une menace venue de l'extérieur et là
encore pointé du doigt l'opposition de
certains états du g5 sahel à la
présidence du mali lieu aux manoeuvres
d'un état extra régionale
visant désespérément isoler notre pays
le mali
le mali se rapproche de plus en plus de
la russie et s'éloigne chaque jour un
peu plus des états occidentaux plus tôt
ce mois ci la junte au pouvoir avait
rompu les accords de défense encadrant
la présence sur le sol malien de la
force française barkan et de la force
européenne takouba
et puis sachez que paris a exprimé ses
regrets après l annonce du départ du
mali de l'organisation régionale
sahélienne g5 sahel la france estime que
cette décision compromettait les efforts
régionaux de lutte contre le terrorisme
et traduisent l isolement du pouvoir
malien jérôme pigné est notre invité ce
soir président et cofondateur du réseau
de réflexion stratégique sur la sécurité
au sahel et chercheur associé à
l'institut thomas smur merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous pour le moment bamako
accuse un état occidental sans citer un
pays nommément mais on devine tout de
même qu'il s'agit de la france quelles
conséquences ces accusations pourraient
avoir sur sur le terrain
alors les conséquences directes de ces
accusations c'est difficile de répondre
à cette question à ce stade en revanche
on peut plutôt anticiper analyser les
conséquences qui sont d'ordre multiples
et dont les impacts seront à géométrie
variable
sur l'annoncé de la suspension pendant
ce temps il s'agit uniquement de la
suspension par rapport au g5 sahel parce
qu il y a deux actualités qui se
chevauchent à la fois l'annoncé le
communiqué dimanche soir par le porte
parole du gouvernement malien de cette
suspension par rapport à l'ensemble du
cadre de coopération et des instances du
g5 sahel et dans la foulée on nous
informe en informe la communauté
internationale par le biais d'un autre
communauté donc le lendemain moins de 24
heures après qu'il y avait eu une
tentative de coup d'état au mali et dans
la continuité de du narratif
la transition politique et de cette la
junte au pouvoir on accuse à demi mot
finalement des puissances étrangères et
évidemment on pense tout de suite à la
france qui aurait d'une part eu un rôle
à jouer dans la difficulté pour le mali
à
collaborer et à prendre cette présidence
du g5 sahel et d'autre part elle serait
directement ou indirectement la source
août l'un des facteurs à prendre en
compte dans une éventuelle dans un
éventuel une éventuel coup d'état au
mali qui se serait passé entre dans la
nuit du 11 vont tout serait donc tout ça
est à la fois très nébuleux dans un
contexte que l'on connaît qui est
particulièrement volatils les
conséquences c'est surtout à très court
terme que le mali continue de s'isoler
par rapport à ses partenaires régionaux
et par rapport à une partie de la
communauté internationale en particulier
la france et ses partenaires de l'union
européenne alors la france estime que le
retrait du mal et du g5 set ça elle
remet en question les efforts régionaux
de lutte contre le terrorisme pensez
vous que le g5 ça elle survivra au
départ du mali
alors s'il s'avérait que le mali des
sites véritablement de quitter de
manière définitive le g5 celle ce serait
de toute façon pour la symbolique et sur
la dimension politique ce qu'une
séquence politique et diplomatique qui
est très forte ce serait un véritable
coup dur pour une institution sous
régionale qui rappelons le n'a pas
encore fêté sa première décade puisqu'il
est né en 2014 et à partir de 2015 on a
commencé à opérationnaliser de chaissac
sel et c'est véritablement à partir de
2017 qu'on met en oeuvre la force
conjointe du g5 celle à ne pas confondre
cette force conjointe et le g5 réel dans
sa globalité qui prend en compte des
apps les approches et des objectifs
civils ou militaires donc c'est par
essence un coup dur pour une
organisation sous régionale que beaucoup
considéraient comme timoré notamment en
matière opérationnelle leur en termes de
leadership et quoi qu'il arrive cette
séquence quand je disais qu'il est très
fort sur le plan politique et
diplomatique aura dé facto des
conséquences sur l'isolation d'une part
du mali même si aujourd'hui le
magnétique il rompt ses relations
suspend ses relations avec eux j'ai 5
c'est là qu'elle est prête à continuer
en bilatéral quid de la réaction des
partenaires je ne parle même pas de la
communauté internationale mais des
partenaires régionaux qui travaille avec
le mali dans d'autres cadres
institutionnels que ça soit l'autorité
du diktat au phoma avec le burkina et le
niger la cedeao l'ami celle qui un
mandat de l'union africaine et plus
largement au niveau continental
l'union africaine donc c'est un coup
d'arrêt dont les conséquences civilo
militaires et politiques seront encore à
apprécier dans les semaines et dans les
mois à venir mais d'une manière générale
ce que l'on peut dire objectivement
c'est que le mali est dans une sorte de
continuité dans son approche qui vise à
6 2 dans un certain nombre de
partenaires historiques alors quelles
conséquences sécuritaires sur sur la
région ont dit que le g5 ça elle n'était
pas efficace mais est-ce que sans cette
force ça ne sera pas pire finalement
alors encore une fois la difficulté
c'était la montée en puissance de la
force conjointe de la montée en
puissance de la coopération régionale
c'est à dire cette capacité notamment
des états à coopérer cette capacité des
états à partager de l'information
partagée du renseignement ce qu'il faut
dire également c'est que le g5 ça elle
n'intervenait pas directement à travers
des puissances étrangères aux régionales
sur le territoire manière c'est
véritablement d'une mise en oeuvre d'un
outil hybride au niveau sous régional
donc la souveraineté du mali ne
dépendait pas et ne dépend pas du g5
celle en revanche comme je le disais on
est dans un contexte politico
diplomatique et stratégique qui est
particulièrement volatil et c'est la
confiance c'est cette capacité aux états
à définir des objectifs communs qui va
être non pas anéanti à ce stade il est
peut-être trop de boulot dit en tout cas
fragiliser
merci beaucoup à jérôme pigné vous êtes
je le rappelle président et cofondateur
du réseau de réflexion stratégique sur
la sécurité au sahel et chercheur
associé à l'institut thomas more merci
beaucoup pour décryptage au burkina faso
les chances de retrouver vivants les
mineurs bloqués depuis un mois dans la
mine de perkoa s'amenuisent aucun mineur
n'a été retrouvé dans la chambre de
refuge les chercheurs comptent les
recherches pardon continue depuis
l'incident aucun contact radio n'a pu
être établi avec les mineurs coincés
dans les galeries écoutez
pas du tout facile elle une déception
mais bon on va continuer toujours dans
la prière et espérons vraiment avoir les
informations sur nos frères comme on le
dirait tout ce que dieu fait est bon
l'essentiel c'est vraiment de retrouver
nos frères
les retrouver nous avons atteint une
étape aujourd'hui où tous nos espoirs
étaient fondés sur la chambre du fils
malheureusement pour nous comme je l'aï
dit tantôt l'on propose nous avons
beaucoup prié poussa et au finish ce
n'est pas ce qui est dit nous devons
vide et vidé la mine de tout son nom est
inspecté hier des pour permettre à la
mairie de meaux
voilà propos recueillis par notre
correspondant à ouagadougou banga
l'ituri nord-est de l'actualité en bref
et en images au tchad max lohan gare
porte parole de la coalition ouaki tama
a été interpellé ce mardi selon des
sources judiciaires l'avocat est
poursuivi pour trouble à l'ordre public
et dans la même procédure que les autres
leaders d'opinion interpellé samedi
dernier la coalition au ouaki tama avait
appelés à marcher contre la politique
française au tchad des manifestations
avaient eu lieu dans plusieurs villes du
pays en libye le chef du gouvernement
soutenue par le maréchal khalifa sall
s'est retiré mardi de tripoli après
avoir tenté de déloger l'exécutif rival
en place ces combats entre groupes armés
ont duré plusieurs heures ils sont d'une
ampleur sans précédent à tripoli depuis
l'échec en juin 2020 de la tentative du
maréchal haftar de s'emparer de la
capitale par la force
le soutien de macky sall à idrissa gueye
dans un tweet le président sénégalais a
pris parti pour le joueur du psg
affirmant que ses convictions
religieuses doivent être respectées
idrissa gueye était absent lors d'un
match dédié au combat contre
l'homophobie il n'aurait pas souhaité
manifester son soutien à la communauté
lgbt
et avant de se quitter je vous emmène à
la rencontre de kabila mais un jeune
immigré sénégalais de 22 ans il est
devenu une célébrité grâce au réseau
social tik tok le jeune homme a grandi
en italie d'où il a enregistré deux
courtes vidéos qu'ils postent sur
internet et qui ont fait de lui un des
influenceurs les plus suivis au monde
natalia mendoza notre correspondante est
allé à sa rencontre
il est devenu un phénomène mondial de la
toile grâce à une idée simple tournée en
dérision les tutoriels d'astuces qu'on
trouve sur internet comme ici cette
personne montre comment couper un titre
en bourse et tu t'habilles l'âme et lui
propose une version bien plus simple
le tout sans dire un mot
et vidéos faire des vidéos muette c'est
ma façon de me faire comprendre partout
dans le monde
dans mes vidéos je ne parle pas mais
j'utilise les expressions faciales les
gestes je bouge mes mains et à la fin
les gens comprennent ce plus richement
dotées des sketches qu'il conclut
toujours avec ce geste désormais sa
marque de fabrique
fès voilà je le fais tellement souvent
que mes mains sont usés
et ça marche sur le réseau social tik
tok kabila mais est aujourd'hui le
deuxième compte le plus suivi au monde
certaines de ses vidéos atteignent plus
de 200 millions de vies
il est drôle et avec un simple geste il
va divertir les gens
[Musique]
il est très drôle et c'est quelqu'un de
très simple en même temps ou bien tu
devrais te plaît j'aime le fait qu'il a
commencé à faire ses vidéos de cheveux
il est parti de rien et il arrivé si vos
pas
avant de devenir une star de la toile
kabila mais enchaîné les petits boulots
dans la périphérie milanaise c'est là
qu'il a grandi avec sa famille
originaire du sénégal
j'ai un lien très fort avec le sénégal
j'espère qu'un jour j'y retournerai
j'aimerais y aller pour faire des
oeuvres de bienfaisance peut-être aidé
quelques écoles vous apporter des choses
dont ils ont besoin
désormais les grandes marques de la mode
frappe à sa porte pour des campagnes
publicitaires et il n'est pas rare de
croiser son image dans les rues du
shopping à milan
à l'as fait la fin de journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes enrichir
notre chef d'édition célia karacena et
merci à vous de nous être fidèles restés
avec nous la faut continuer sur france
[Musique]